[Music]
so time then for the press preview lots
to talk about as we take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages tonight we'll see
what's making the headlines with rachel
watson and peter gagan speak to them in
a moment after we've had a look at those
front pages for you starting with the
telegraph and on the eve of the new
prime minister being announced the
telegraph reports front-runner liz truss
is considering freezing energy bills for
millions of households this winter if
she wins
the daily express also leads on comments
made by mistrust promising immediate
action to help with soaring energy bills
according to the mirror liz truss is
still a week away from having a cost of
living plan
but the times reports that she is to
announce a vast support package to deal
with surging energy costs including a
gas and electricity price freeze
the front-runner to be the next prime
minister also features on the front of
the guardian as you can see there it
says she will press on with tax cuts
while the ft quotes quasi-cuate as he
sets out to reassure markets that
mistrust will not blow a hole in the
public finances if she gets the top job
he of course may end up as chancellor
the eye front reports pm in waiting with
a picture of the front runner once again
liz truss
bbc comic mocks liz truss is the
headline on the daily mail referring of
course to comedian joe lysett's
appearance on laura koonsberg's new show
the metro reports on the arrest of three
new suspects by police hunting the
masked gunman who shot dead
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell in
liverpool a four night ago
and the daily star reports that pubs
need help with energy costs or customers
will face an increase in the price of
pints
and don't forget just scan the qr code
that you can see on screen join the
program and you can check out the front
pages of twitter's papers while you
watch us discussing them and i'm joined
tonight by political editor of the
scottish sun rachel watson also
editor-in-chief at open democracy peter
gagan great to see you both this sunday
evening and we have a lot to talk about
on the eve of what is going to be a
momentous week in westminster uh rachel
perhaps we can start with you and in
fact the telegraph and the times both
with very similar headlines the
telegraph saying trust could freeze
bills to avoid energy armageddon the
times saying trust team hold talks on
freezing energy bills she wasn't
particularly forthcoming today was she
when she was interviewed about what her
plans
are but it does seem well she certainly
didn't rule out or rule in freezing
bills that's something labour's been
calling for rachel
yeah so there's one theme that dominates
the front pages tomorrow and obviously
that is basically that is the the new
prime minister who is expected to be liz
tross i'm in a little over 12 hours
announced and
the energy crisis that we are all in the
grip of at the moment and and the
telegraphing times seem to have got a
little bit more information than others
and as you said liz trust this morning
she didn't give much away she said that
if she is the new prime minister she
will act within the week to bring
forward more support and help families
and businesses across the country and
what we learned from the telegraph in
the times tomorrow is that
liz trust is planning to freeze energy
bills to avoid as they say this
armageddon and that families are facing
now what we don't know are the specifics
of that so um there's chat within these
stories people have spoken to campaign
insiders they've spoken to energy
company insiders who say
they expect a freeze to be announced in
the next few days but we don't know you
know who will that impact what will that
freeze be what you know where where on
the scale can we expect the freeze to be
how much will people still have to pay
where will that money come from so all
these details we still don't have we
just know a little bit more and that liz
trust might be minded now to look at an
energy freeze
there's also talk within these two
pieces of the help that she will
announce being
greater than the money that was spent on
uh furlough so you know we are expecting
now if liz trust as well expect is named
prime minister tomorrow for there to be
some huge package now whether she has
that or that this is just you know a
bump in the papers ahead of her being
announced prime minister tomorrow we
don't know but there is huge pressure
for whoever the next prime minister is
to deal with this energy crisis yeah and
you know they will have to come forward
within the first few days because of the
paralysis the government has been under
for the last two months that's right and
uh peter it was interesting hearing from
our political editor between b tonight
saying she's been speaking to sources
close to liz tras who say it's going to
be a big bang approach a shock and awe
moment
bigger than many people expect that
something is needed and it is needed
soon
well this is a huge thing for liz trust
and in some ways it's it's either it is
it probably is go big or go home because
if this is not a big enough package if
this is not a big enough approach he's
had plenty of time to think about it we
spent now six weeks when we know who the
effective new prime minister is going to
be nothing has really happened uh to try
and address this issue and if it isn't
big enough and if she gets criticized
you know if it's criticized for not
being big enough that will i think
probably come to define her entire
premiership so it really is a huge
moment there's a lot of briefing that's
going to be as big as the furlough
scheme kind of ironically given that uh
some of liz trust's supporters uh
viciously attacked chris during the tory
leadership campaign for the fertile
scheme for the amount of money to spend
on that but i think that's the reality
of the situation this is this is going
to require massive estate intervention
otherwise people are going to literally
die in their homes this uh this winter
so it's now finally been briefed it's
still quite bare in terms of what we
know about it and some of the papers as
you as said at the start really you know
are criticizing this trust for us you
know there's been a lot of time and
there's huge amounts of time just had to
come up with a plan so finally some
details are emerging and but for a lot
of people it's still something that you
know they're not clear we're still not
clear what exactly it's going to look
like yeah interesting seeing the front
of the mirror uh saying trust wait a
week for crisis plan um saying you know
yet more delay um let's talk about the
front of the guardian uh shall we rachel
because of course it's not not just
britain suffering with the the cost of
living crisis germany hit particularly
hard because of their reliance on on
russian energy and olef schultz has been
uh promising the people of germany some
help
yeah so i think this is another area
where there will be pressure for liz
truss to act immediately when she comes
in because as you say it's not only the
uk that's in the middle of this energy
crisis there are other countries across
the world across europe who are
suffering and we see now additional
support in these countries coming
forward that will
you know keep that pressure on as i said
so um we know in germany all of schultz
announced today relief worth around 65
billion euros around roughly 56 million
pounds worth of relief and for to cut
consumer prices of gas oil and coal
and a windfall tax on electricity
providers as well so we've seen this
action in other countries where you know
as peter says as we discussed there's
been almost a paralysis in the uk for
the last two months while this toy
leadership competition has gone on now
there has been help
and in some ways but there's a lot of
additional support that's needed and
we're seeing this in other countries at
the moment as new packages are announced
and i think this will feed in this week
to that pressure of the new that the new
prime minister is under i think as peter
says you know this has got to be go big
or go home because we're seeing other
people act so you know if this doesn't
if liz trust doesn't have a plan that's
already well thought out that is well
progressed
you know she's had a lot of time to deal
with this this is the top of her entry
and it has been for the whole of this
story leadership competition and you
know it has to be dealt with immediately
and if there's not a plan there she will
be criticized and i think it could
define her going forward you know we're
not that far off from a general election
even if there's not a snap election as
some people think there might be so i
think this is something that we need to
see not only that pressure at home but
there will be pressure looking around
overseas at how it's dealt with you know
countries like germany as you mentioned
they do have that additional pressure of
where they get their oil and gas from
and the supply but here you know there
does need to be action immediately and
they will be looking at other countries
and what they're doing yeah who would
want uh who would want this job uh peter
um the front of the ft is talking about
the markets they're obviously extremely
jittery and concerned about uh all of
this and what's going to happen their
headline trusts will be safe hand on
public finances pledges ally quartering
uh anyone would think he's after a job
yes who could possibly uh who could
possibly imagine he might be and
obviously crossover is a long-term ally
of of liz trust they kind of come from
that kind of right to the tory party um
co-authors of books together etc so this
is it's an interesting place for quarter
tank to make this intervention as well
the ft rule on a very critical front
page of trusses economics
at their weekend paper yesterday in
which they basically crunched their own
numbers and were arguing that the
supposed fiscal headroom that trust says
there is for tax cuts just doesn't exist
now because of inflation even since she
made those promises so you know maybe
this is an attempt by quarter time but
you'd imagine by trust as well to try
and get some credibility and legitimacy
because she has been heavily criticized
for her economic policies and even this
morning when she was speaking to laura
coonsburg talking about how
the real problem has been this kind of
focus on redistribution over the last 20
years which would be a surprise to a lot
of people giving that real term wages
having risen are still at 2007 levels
and inequalities risen massively over
the last 15 or 20 years too so you know
trust is seen as coming from the
slightly cranky tory right in many
respects and this feels like an attempt
to try and put them a bit more in the
center yeah rachel what do what do you
make of uh uh
i mean if it is liz trust of course
we're assuming it's going to be but if
she is the new prime minister
what about how split the party is
because uh more than two-thirds of tory
mps uh in the first round didn't vote
for her can she uh bring the party
together i mean boris johnson pleading
in yesterday's papers that the the the
party needs to be united behind
i her again this is a huge task for the
next prime minister because we did see
huge splits with the conservative party
at the end you know towards the end uh
before boris johnson resigned we're
still seeing those splits the start of
this leadership competition was quite
nasty when you look at how some of the
candidates were treated the briefings to
the press so there's a huge task there
because people are still unhappy about
how boris johnson handled partygate for
example how he was in government and
list trust is not seen as that a full
breakaway you just see who some of the
potential cabinet ministers are for
example not huge breakaways from boris
johnson's government in scotland we had
people briefing and before we got down
to the final two of what a disaster liz
trusts would be for the union and for
the scottish conservatives now she is
getting support up here
that came fairly late on uh but she does
have some msps backing her in scott's mp
but i think you know there's um a lot of
work to try and gain the trust of the
party and as i said before we're not
that far away from an election so that
has to be done fairly quickly as well so
there's a lot of tasks here for the
prime minister now obviously the first
task is dealing with the cost of living
crisis pulling together for the country
and but in her mind as well she will be
thinking about the future of the party
there's huge concern about the damage
that's already been done to the
conservatives will that be lasting
damage for example if they do lose an
election how long could they be out of
power all these things will be going
through people's minds in the
conservative party as we come to the end
of this leadership contest yeah just
before we go to the break peter your
thoughts on this has been so much blue
on blue fighting hasn't there lots of uh
squabbling over the last few weeks can
liz trust as well as everything else
bring the party together
yeah casting forward from where we are
today obviously we'll we'll get the the
results tomorrow etcetera and liz trusom
will certainly become prime minister on
tuesday but probably the most
interesting thing is is what will happen
next the cabinet
and there's not that much briefings in
the paper there's been some briefings in
the sundays today about what where that
might go who will be in her cabinet who
will she keep from the boris johnson
administration who will she bring in the
support of rishi sunak et cetera et
cetera et cetera and i think that will
be quite a big internal conservative
party issue and the other thing is that
for a lot of people in the country they
don't really know who liz trust is uh
and it remains to be seen quite how
convinced they will be by liz trust once
they see her because she is re you know
for a lot of people outside of the likes
of us who sit on late night television
programs she's not someone that has had
a huge stature she's been the foreign
secretary yes but she's not someone
that's a kind of a defining political
figure of the last 10 or 15 years so
there's a lot of other kind of
machinations of conservative party and
how they might react given how the
public views her in the coming weeks and
months would be quite will keep us all
entertained i mean it really will so
much work to do all right both thank you
for the moment we're going to take a
quick break coming up the daily mail
focuses on comedian joe light its
appearance on laura koonsburg's new show
bbc comic mocs liz truss is at their
headline discussing that and more next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back parts of the press preview
rachel and peter still with us uh rachel
front page of the daily mail uh the mail
having uh pop at the bbc after a comic
appears on a political show this morning
yes so again in keeping with the theme
of tory leadership but slightly
different and not really addressing the
cost of living crisis rather
as you say july set on laura kingsburg's
show on bbc today um and you know having
a bit of a pop at him over his sarcasm
um
when he was on there and i think you
know uh he's a comedian and i'm sure the
bbc were well aware of um
his his views and how he is
when he was booked so i think you know
i've looked on twitter today and saw um
both you know there's two sides there's
people having a goal i thought it was
interesting that they decided this was
the way to go rather than talk about the
cost of living crisis and the other
papers have and but i think you know
there are you know liz trust spoke on
the television this morning and as we've
spoken about and as we can see across a
lot of the papers she didn't tell us
very much about what she was going to
say and she said that a plan for the
energy crisis would be unveiled within a
week even when we've got briefings in
some of the papers we find out
um just little bits you know not all the
details
and i think you know as i said earlier
she's going to be unveiled as the next
prime minister we think uh within the
next just over 12 hours so you know i
think there's a little bit to be said
he's a comedian on a sunday morning
television show and you know how
seriously should we be taking um his
reaction to liz trust and you know it
was meant and in humor he is a comedian
he can't i mean you can't book it you
can't book a comedian and then and then
say that uh
that you don't like his jokes can you i
mean
it's a i suppose there are two things
here peter aren't there firstly is it
right for a political show in a very
serious time to have a comedian on
giving his thoughts and secondly uh what
do you make of this slightly old front
page for the mail given that we're on
the eve of this at this huge week in
westminster
i'm so i'm just amazed that it took two
bylines to write this story you know
there's as far as i can gather from the
front pages there's basically nothing in
it and i think you know it's it was the
fact that there was so much combination
today about what joe license did which
is effectively send up the entire genre
of political shows and the in fact you
know the fact that as rachel says let's
trust it very little on the television
and what uh what joe license was doing
was what lots of other people who
frankly have even less qualifications to
do so than joe lysat from you know
anonymously funded think thanks to
fairly random people from the internet
who have political
persuasions in one direction or who get
put on to uh daytime television shows
and and asked to to wax lyric on the
politics of the day you know i think
what joe lysa did was send all of that
up and in some ways it really i think
hammered home just how little liz trust
had actually said you know and i think
you know we've kind of in some ways as
well tend to treat politics as
entertainment i think probably we all
have i think i said at the end of the
last clip about how it'll be an
entertaining few months whatever happens
we tend to kind of look about at
politics as entertainment in some ways
and it's really really not it's a really
serious thing and you know what she's
talking about the cost of living crisis
it's going to affect you know literally
tens of billions of people tens of
millions of people in this country and
she's not saying what she's going to do
and it must be really it's very
stressful especially for people who've
got kids and families and trying
already struggling to survive what's
going to happen okay we just got 30
seconds left um she wasn't she doesn't
turn up on television and talk about it
yeah sorry just breaking up there
slightly um we've just got 20 seconds to
talk about the enemy of the state um
trump blasting biden uh just give me one
sentence on this rachel
i mean given how divisive politics is
and not only here but in the us it's a
pretty um
you know
irresponsible thing to say but again it
is the former president trump saying it
so you know
should we expect this but i think given
the the heat in politics we saw what
happened at the capitol previously
um to still be talking like this is you
know is really kind of
it's difficult
yeah we'll discuss it further
after uh in about half an hour thanks
both very much